arrivé au pouvoir en l'an 2000 vladimir
poutine a côtoyé quatre présidents
français des relations diplomatiques qui
commence avec le plus russophiles de
tous niveaux
avec jacques chirac vladimir poutine
s'opposent en 2003 à l'intervention
américaine en irak une position commune
qui rapproche les deux hommes jacques
chirac a décidé au dernier moment de
venir à roissy accueillir lui-même
vladimir poutine quand on déroge au
protocole très strict d'une visite
d'état c'est évidemment pour donner à
son geste une portée politique ils se
respectent et se décore la légion
d'honneur pour vladimir poutine en 2006
en 2008 le prix d'état pour jacques
chirac la plus haute distinction russe
remise par dimitri medvedev
vladimir poutine sera aussi le seul chef
d'une grande puissance aux obsèques de
jacques chirac
après lui c'est nicolas sarkozy qui
rencontrent pour la première fois
vladimir poutine lors d'un sommet du g8
c'est un peu un concours de bonne humeur
auquel se sont livrés les chefs d'état
avec mention spéciale au tandem poutine
sarkozy à la complicité très médiatisé
il m'a dit que j'étais direct et j'ai
dit oui je m'inspire de vous aussi sauf
qu'en coulisse la dîmière poussines
aurait fait comprendre à nicolas sarkozy
qu'il ne voulait pas parler des sujets
qui fâchent comme la tchétchénie ou
l'assassinât de la journaliste anna
politkovskaïa
en 2012 changement d'interlocuteur
françois hollande arrive au pouvoir les
guerres en syrie et en crimée vont
diviser les deux hommes entre eux c'est
glacial comme on dit en diplomatie les
relations sont franches quant à la
chaleur les relations entre la france et
la russie sont chaleureuses aujourd'hui
approchez vous allez sentir la chaleur
pour la chaleur
jugerait vous-même progrès la
température régulièrement de nos
relations en 2010 cette sélection d'
emmanuel macron et le réchauffement des
relations la dîmière poutine est reçu au
château de versailles en 2019 au fort de
brégançon il est un autre récurrent du
président français est un interlocuteur
régulier
emmanuel macron aime le faire savoir il
parle régulièrement avec le président
russe au téléphone comme ici depuis son
avion ses équipiers
une relation compliquée ils se défient
en permanence il ya quelques jours
emmanuel macron s'exclamer nous ne
devrions jamais nous montrer faible face
au président poutine quand vous êtes
faibles il s'en sert une relation ferme
entre les deux hommes qui n'empêche pas
selon l'elysée un contact encore
privilégiée en pleine guerre entre la
russie et l'ukraine
[Musique]